[Music]  demi lovato rushed to the hospital after  suffering an apparent drug overdose  according to a report from TMZ the 25  year old singer was reportedly  transported from a home in the Hollywood  Hills just before noon on Tuesday and is  currently being treated her condition at  this time is unknown Demi has openly  fought substance abuse for years and  recently opened up about relapsing in  her new song sober everyone goes through  ups and downs and I'm getting to write  about that and I'm sorry for the fans I  lost who watch me fall again I wanna be  a role model but I'm I've been able to  share my story with other people and  I've had fans that come up to me and  tell me you know because you got sober I  got sober